we're told kenzie makes quilts with some
blue squares and some green squares the
ratio of blue squares to green squares
is shown in the diagram
the table shows the number of blue
squares and the number of green squares
that kenzie will make on two of her
quilts all right this is the table
they're talking about based on the ratio
complete the missing values in the table
so why don't you pause this video and
see if you can figure it out
well first let's think about the ratio
of blue to green squares so for every
three blue squares let me do that same a
similar color for every three blue
squares we are going to have one two
three four five green squares
so the ratio of blue to green is three
to five
and so in quilt a she has 21 blue
squares so she has 21 blue squares how
many green squares would she have well
to go from 3 to 21 you have to multiply
by 7.
and so
you would take 5 and then multiply that
by 7
so you'd multiply 5 times 7 to get to 35
as long as you multiply both of these by
the same number or divide them by the
same number you're going to get an
equivalent ratio so 21 to 35 is the same
thing as 3 to 5.
now we have a situation quilt b they've
given us the number of green squares so
that's 20.
well how do we get 20 from 5 well we
would multiply by 4.
so if you multiply the number of green
squares by 4 then you would do the same
thing for the number of blue squares 3
times 4
3 times 4 is going to be equal to 12. 12
blue squares for every 20 green squares
is the same ratio as three blue squares
for every five green squares let's do
another example
here we are told the following diagram
describes the number of cups of blue and
red paint in a mixture
what is the ratio of blue paint to red
paint in the mixture so try to work it
out
all right so let's just see we have one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
ten cups of blue paint for every
one two three four five six cups of red
bait
so this would be a legitimate ratio a
ratio of 10 cups of blue paint for every
six cups of red paint but this isn't in
i guess you could say lowest terms or
most simplified terms because we can
actually divide both of these numbers by
two so if you divide ten by two you get
five do that blue color
and if you divide six by two you get
three
so one way to think about it is for
every blues every five blue squares you
have three red squares in this diagram
in this tape diagram that's sometimes
called or you could say for every five
cups of blue paint you have three cups
of red paint in our mixture and you can
even see that here so three cups of red
paint and one two three four five
and five
cups of blue paint and you see that
again
right over here
let's do another example
here we're told luna and ginny each cast
magic spells the ratio of spells
lunacast to spells ginny casts is
represented in this tape diagram alright
based on the ratio what is the number of
spells ginny casts when luna casts 20
spells
pause this video see if you can work it
out
all right so let's just see the ratio
here for every
one two three four spells
that luna casts ginny casts
one two three four five spells so the
ratio is four to five
but if luna casts 20 spells
so if luna casts 20 spells well to go
from 4 to 20 we had to multiply by 5.
and so we would do the same thing with
the number of spells ginny cass you'd
multiply that by 5. so it's 25. so 4
luna spells for every five ginny spells
is the same thing as 20 luna spells for
every 25 ginny spells and so how many
how many spells does jenny cast when lou
and luna cast 20 spells
she casts 25 and we're done